- You see.
When we come into this world,
you like a domestic animal,
or an animal going in the wild.
So anything that's born
from an egg is an animal.
Now according to history and our books,
humans are the highest form of an animal.
So we say.
But as we come up in life,
you have babies that was born in a home.
Raised with character,
raised with their families.
We went on this topic before
in one of my other interviews,
but it's the same topic
but a little different.
When we come up into these
homes with our family
and our character, you wind up not having
a character of your own because
you have been put in a position
where you have to care and absolutely
had to care for others.
Your brothers, your sisters.
And it wasn't a choice for
you to care for others,
this is just the human way.
We share the bathroom, we
share the breakfast table.
We have to be considerate of
our mother and our father.
So, as you evolve and, like as opposed
to an animal born in the wild.
You get your puppies out there,
they fend, as they grow they fend,
like pigeons they fight for their food.
Mom teach you how to hunt,
and then it's on you.
And you know if your brother
got a bigger piece of meat
and you born in the wild,
you got to, like a wolf,
fight for that meat.
Education is something that
comes in every form of life.
Take a guy like me.
You have people who went to college
and had high school degrees,
as opposed to a guy who's
never been to school
a day in his life.
Never had a phone, he's
computer illiterate.
He don't read books, hardly
ever been to a library
or nothing, no brothers, no
sisters, no wife and kids.
But, to hear this mean speak
and the topics he speak on,
you would think that he's been educated
in some of the highest
institutions America has to offer.
But he wasn't.
He grew up in the wild, born in the wild,
grew up in the street.
But the different cultures he lived in
showed him things and learned him things.
Like walking down the street
looking at a store window
and staring at it until
you knew how to read it,
until you taught yourself how to read it.
So life will evolve for you,
if you give it a chance.
But the problem with most people is,
that they see so many
things that they want to do
and they want in life,
that they really don't
give themselves a chance to evolve,
'cause they pushing themselves so hard
to get the car, to go on a
cruise, to see Rome, Paris.
To have the big house with
the family and the kids.
And if these things don't
materialize for them,
then depression set in.
Because you feel you didn't
evolve far enough in life.
Then you start looking
for other things to blame,
like if I hadn't married
my husband too soon,
if I hadn't had the babies too soon,
if I hadn't listened to
my brother, my mother,
if I did what I wanted to do.
And these things stress you out.
And so by the time you feel
you can get it back on track,
it has took too many years,
now your pensions and
your retirement funds
have come in jeopardy,
because you feel like
you made a lot of wrong decisions.
When life is not racism,
and it's not the people that's the enemy.
You are your own enemy,
because you want so much.
And you want more than you can pay for.
And when these things don't happen,
you wanting to blame the world.
People commit suicide, kill their babies,
throw them in fires.
They have babies at home and
put 'em in a garbage can.
Abort 'em at home.
Everything.
And every species.
We feel we're the highest form of species.
But, if you pay attention to animals,
animals don't sit up and
turn on you and lie to you.
Your dog will die for
you and kill for you.
Without any question.
But your brother who come
up in the house with y'all
when you get grown, someday
y'all will get angry
at each other and won't even
speak to you no more in life.
And your own mother
will tell her own child
to get out the house and never come back.
And the child will steal
from his own mother,
and go in her purse.
Take his brother's wallet.
And all this for a drug.
Or for a car payment.
For a pair of Jordan shoes.
And when you see a
crack-head or a heroin-head,
you have to ask yourself
what kind of head am I?
Because the guy that owns
the Lexus or the Rolls-Royce,
he gonna go to work everyday
and work hard as he can
to pay for that Rolls-Royce
and that mansion out in Beverly Hills,
and the land he lives on,
and send his children to Harvard or Yale.
Somewhere like that.
So that they can try to
have a good education.
In his own kids' mind,
they don't want to do that.
Daddy left me $10
million, when will he die?
They look at their own
fathers and mothers,
and say they too healthy.
They're not dying soon.
We can't get the will, the $10 million,
the estate, the big house.
In history, I will bring this up,
as the OJ trial and the
Nicole Simpson trial.
Bad feud between the two but
he can't let that girl go.
Because he feels he'll
lose everything he got.
So some mutiny have to come into play.
It's public news, so there's nothing there
can be said about that.
'Cause it's all over the news.
This is just my personal
opinion about that.
The Menendez brothers.
My parents abused us.
But they're not here to tell you that now.
And you killed them.
And then you thought
you was gonna get money,
but they took them to two trials
until they broke them,
now as far as I know
they may be in prison for
the rest of their lives.
Haven't followed up on that.
But over the history of time,
when you say education,
education never stops.
Because every decade, every ten years,
we change, technology change things.
So when you have spent your money
to go to Harvard and Yale in the 60's,
in the 70's, you will
see that this knowledge
merely don't count no more.
Because the stuff you learned in the 80's,
you have to re-educate
yourself for the 90's.
And the stuff you learned in the 90's,
you have to re-educate
yourself for the 2000's.
And who knows what will happen by 2030,
we might have spaceship cars, flying.
I'm 63.
So I don't know that
I'll be here to see that.
But you might have red
lights up in the sky.
And how many tickets
will you give in the sky
when you got 50000 cars flying,
passing each other doing 70 miles an hour
in the big wide open sky?
They feel that we don't have
to obey a speed limit up here.
And can you put a speed
sign up in mid-air?
Or will they have to build
some kind of contrapment
up there to stick poles in the sky
and say you can only do 35 miles an hour.
Up by this cloud.
My point is when you talk about God.
See a lot of people when we going God,
a lot of people thought about religion.
And we put evil and a good
entity facing each other.
That's not what it's about.
You see, the war in
heaven was about Lucifer,
which was God's mightiest angels,
and God saying, I'ma give the
people what they want too.
The cars and the houses and all that.
But we don't want them to learn too fast,
so they'll know how to adapt
to these type of things.
Without hurting each other and
without killing each other.
And then when Lucifer argument would be,
oh, you want to control them.
Why not just put it out
there and let them decide.
Because then they'll
be hurting each other,
like are you sure about that?
Or do you just want
them under your control?
So then we took it over
and the Bible was made.
So we took it as evil
fighting a religious thing.
Evil versus positive.
Or however you want to say it.
Good and evil.
But it wasn't about that,
it was like two brothers
come up in the house.
One say, well Mom say I want to buy a car,
but let's get the station wagon.
No, let's get the Camaro over there.
Well what about the kids?
Same thing in heaven.
Let's give it to 'em.
Let them handle it.
God controls heaven.
I'm the Father.
You are just my son.
Just like you would go against
your own father in the house.
I'm your dad.
We not gon' do it like this.
Or you're gon' get out of my house.
But we turned it into a war in heaven.
So he kicked him out his house.
You do it your way then.
He was rich, he had power.
He wasn't God but he had power.
Had his own money or whatever.
Started this thing, what we call evil.
Cars, drugs, money.
And the people loved it.
And when he went to God, his
father, he said they love it.
But yes, but they hurting each other.
And they killing each other behind it.
And so we made it that.
What we was going to
have all the same things,
just one felt like we
should have took our time,
and got to adapt to
this and learn to this,
'cause he wanted you to
appreciate life for life.
Not appreciate life for
what it can give you.
Or what you could get out of it.
Because he knew that
someday you would die,
and you cannot take any of this with you.
And if you live like
that, not appreciating
life for life, and
appreciating life for things,
then your children will follow that.
Like a man come up drinking in the house,
beating up his wife.
His sons will get drunk,
and see his dad doing it.
And before you know it, 12 years old,
they gon' slap a girl, bow!
The first time is hard.
Then it gets easier as you drink.
The second time is easier.
The third time is easier.
The problem with me is I
never, ever hit a girl.
Called a lot girls bitches,
and sluts, and whores.
They ripped me off.
But I could never bring myself to hit one,
because I knew, once
you crossed that line,
there's no point to return.
Like to drink.
I never had to drink in my life.
Not because I was better,
because I'm homeless out here
with everybody else and don't
have a dime in the world.
No brothers no sisters,
again, like I said,
no wife and kids.
But I never took one sip of that alcohol.
Because when I saw what it
was doing to my friends,
I did not want myself to turn into that.
I did not hit the crack
pipe, I did not do crystal,
I did not do heroin, I
did not do powder coke.
But I do do a drug, and
it involves marijuana.
Well I don't do this
to make myself better,
but you will never, ever enjoy life,
until you can learn to relax
and appreciate life for life.
Because it has so much to offer,
and we so busy running for things.
Like you take that GameBoy.
Or that Xbox.
You buy a game for that Xbox,
and every time you buy a game,
you got to buy a new machine.
So you have to ask yourself,
how many kids I got in my family?
And how many machines am I
gonna buy and spoil this person,
before I decide that I'm not
gonna spend another $300.
And you take those Jordans.
Michael Jordan is damn
good basketball player,
and I have nothing against him.
Magic Johnson, all them.
And I love those people on the court.
But we don't even know these people.
And when they die we cry for them,
and we give them all our money.
Three and four hundred
dollars for a pair of Jordans.
And that's nice if you can afford that
because they are pretty shoes.
But if you can't afford that
and you know your child needs to eat,
then why would you buy a pair of Jordans.
Now me, I got a pair of
old-ass Air Force 1 Nikes on.
It was gave to me from a food
line, and they good shoes!
Nice blue and white and thick,
and they ain't nowhere near being tore up.
But I didn't pay a dime for 'em.
And they might not be as new as the ones
you bought at the store for
300, but they in good shape.
And they're good-looking shoes.
And they comfortable, because they have
a little wear on them, so I
didn't have to break them in.
And I say that as a joking matter,
to be more practical, people.
Because life is not going to lay down
and just make it easy for you.
And remember one thing, when
you decide to commit suicide,
or decide you're so depressed
you need to go to a mental
hospital, dying is easy.
All you gotta do is lay down
and close your eyes and lay in a casket.
It's living that's hard.
Because you feel you gotta get up
and face life's everyday problems.
I got to talk to this person,
I got to talk to that person.
I got to get home to the
babysitter that's taking my kid.
I got to re-fuel the car.
The husband ain't doing
nothing but sitting out there
drinking and beating my ass.
Life is hard.
And it won't get any easier.
Until you make it easier.
And it wasn't a war in heaven.
It was a father arguing with his son.
His son wanted to do it one way,
father wanted to do it another.
A lot of us chose the son way.
And some of us are successful
choosing to go with the son way.
Some of them got Beverly
Hills big mansions.
Big beautiful cars.
And they look like they made it.
So they thought.
But they didn't.
Because the people that work for all that
are wearing the pacemakers,
catching corona.
Got nerve problems, high blood pressure.
Running to the stock market in New York,
dropping Alka-Seltzers and
all kind of awesome pills
and heart pills, because
the stock market dropping.
Wife talking about leaving you.
Magic Johnson got AIDS.
Kobe Bryant, excuse me,
I'm sorry he's gone.
Sex problems in Denver.
Now he's dead.
The other guy who played with
the football team killed his wife.
Pregnant wife and baby years ago.
'Cause he felt she was getting in the way.
All this behind material things and money.
And in the end, when you
get 60 or 70, 80 years old,
you say what was it all for?
And how many people did I
walk on over those years
and hurt and abuse,
fuck over, for a price?
We fought wars years ago.
Vietnam, Hitler, war.
Vietnam War.
Alamo, to control population control.
To save money.
To have power and control of the world.
And God said you know when we have power
and control of the world,
the only thing people will
do is many people will die.
Christopher Columbus
discovered America, they say,
but the Indians were here.
General Custer was a hero,
The diamond mines in Africa.
So there was no racism,
no wrong, on any race.
My point was that over
history, man from all races
have tried to dominate and control.
From the Martin Luther King
to the Abraham Lincoln era,
where they were assassinated,
remember these five
assassinations had to happen
in history to make the
world what it is today.
The first assassination was Jesus Christ.
Then it was Abraham
Lincoln freeing the blacks.
Then it was John F. Kennedy
and Robert F. Kennedy.
That's four, six of them.
Then it was Malcolm X
and Martin Luther King.
And the only unsuccessful
assassination was Ronald Reagan,
who they say had 666 in his name.
That was shot in Washington.
And there was a rumor that they thought
he might be the son of Lucifer,
'cause he had the 666 in his name I guess.
All the letters in his
name added up to 666.
I didn't check on that,
but don't quote on me that,
but it was something said
about that years ago.
Get his middle name,
Ronald whatever Reagan,
and then you can compare that to yourself.
This was just a rumor.
Nothing that I saw in any
book or anything like that.
So I'm quoting from a rumor I heard.
But they tried to shoot
him one time in Washington
and he successfully got through that.
Then there was Watergate
with President Nixon.
So everybody is in control.
Then there was a thing with
Fidel Castro and his country,
he wouldn't let nobody in,
controlled the country,
killed people, did
whatever he wanted to do.
Then there was the whole thing with Iraq,
I told ya already he wanted
to control his country,
Saddam Hussein, who they
say was killing all this
and doing such and such and such.
So there, Hitler.
And we going back down to whatever that
motherfucker in Korea name.
The conqueror the great
or something like that.
Back in Asia days.
So over the history of time,
it's always been proven that all men
have tried to dominate the
world without any success.
Got to a certain point of success,
but had always failed to achieve
what they wanted to achieve.
Because God run the world.
And as far as your social things?
Hey, women love sex, sex feel good.
Every female is a prostitute
and every man is a trick.
If you notice with most people,
when you ask a girl what
kind of man she want.
Oh, I want a man that can provide for me,
and give me good security, and
love me, and treat me good,
and take care of the
children, and stay by my side.
And then you ask a man what he want.
Oh, I'd just like a girl
that will love me and obey me
and let me go to work
and take care of my kids
and take care of my house,
and always not be so suspicious of me
because you want to her to stay at home
and take care of the babies,
and have no questions for you.
So you can walk all around
in your private jet,
and go out to your nightclubs at night
and have sluts and
whores all over the city,
because you a big businessman
that go and stay from motel
to motel, all over the city.
And the wife just want to be
a little dumbass motherfucker,
and let you take all
the money and jet around
Los Angeles to all the nightclubs
or even yet go to all
the foreign countries,
Rome, for you big businessmen
that got passports.
You don't think they think you got
a little female over there?
All them beautiful girls in
Rome, Switzerland, Australia.
All them girls looking for y'all.
Denver, Colorado, Aspen.
Paris, New York, and you think yo' woman
like Foot Locker and shoes.
You see a pair of Jordans today,
a new pair come out next
week and you want that pair.
You marry a girl because
she was young and fine
and look good, when she get old, fat,
and have your baby with stretchmarks,
you looking for a new
pair like them shoes.
Another young fine, small-waisted
girl with smooth breasts.
And that's the one you
gon' be cheating with.
And the old lady know it.
And the kids know it.
And now your sons are cheating too
because they see you
doing it and getting drunk
and beating up women and all that too.
And your daughter, see,
don't want one man now.
They even want boy toys.
And you wonder why your daughter having
all this unpromiscuous sex?
'Cause it started at home.
With you.
'Cause when you started cheating,
your wife said well I
don't give a damn neither.
He up in Rome cheating on me,
I'm gonna get drunk and
bring me a man in the house.
Kids see her bring a man in the house.
Or go out, honey, I'll be back later.
Then they get in the car
and follow her to a motel.
And see her getting out
the car and she mad at you.
Now y'all cheating, your
daughter feel like, shit,
I can go on and sling my little butt too.
Shit, fucking is fun.
Sex is fun.
Excuse me for saying it like that
but you have to give it to 'em real.
And if you teach your
daughter and your sons,
teaching them about
the birds and the bees,
and do like my mother told me,
that's why I never had no children.
She sat me down.
She said I'm not gonna
chase you all day like that
and tell you to keep that
little dick of yours in your pants.
Let's get one thing straight.
She told me, you have a baby,
you gon' take care of
it, or I'm gon kill ya.
I won't help you take care of no children.
If you get that responsibility,
you will do this yourself.
You run and leave, your
child support, not mine.
And told me, you know
if you don't pay that
when they catch up with you,
you will have to pay that and back pay.
I suggest you think about this.
Sat down and told me, said
you can drink that liquor.
I got cancer, you ain't
in school watching me,
you can get that alcohol.
You can get drunk, and start
getting your ass kicked
on alcohol, going to
jail and become a loser
like your cousin Benny,
and you know I'm sick
with cancer and can't help.
That's on you.
And you can get them
tattoos and join them gangs,
or do all those hard drugs.
I love you, you're my only son.
I'm gonna only give it to you, like real.
No matter how young you is.
It's not gonna be about
the birds and the bees.
It's gonna be about the
penitentiary, prisons,
lot of bullet wounds, knife scars.
And you'll win some,
'cause I've seen you out there
in the streets fighting
in school and everything.
But for every one you win,
you get a little closer to that loss.
And you can win a thousand
fights, and lose one.
And that one could be so devastating,
that you'll never recover from it.
Which means you could die, get paralyzed,
or go to prison for the rest of your life.
Your decision.
And don't get me wrong.
I never had much sex in my life.
Been a long time, probably
about 12, 13 years.
And I wanted it that way.
I miss it, I used to
watch porno and all that.
And I wanted that high-powered sex.
You know where they freak,
get the girls in there,
man and she do some
wonderful things to you.
It's every black man's dream
to get one of them Spanish girls
and one of them white girls in the butt
or something like that.
When they having that good, powerful sex.
Excuse my language, this
part is only for adults,
I'm just being real.
To be honest and truthful with you.
So, it's a lot of black guys' dream
to get that fine blonde,
that lovely brunette,
or that soft Spanish girl
and just do lovely things,
and y'all just do your
thing about five, six hours.
Make each other feel good.
But at what price?
You have to pay that.
I couldn't give a girl a bunch of crystal
and have her come into the table
with three, four guys dog-eyed.
If we were playing, you know
she do her little thing,
and just me and her somewhere quiet,
and I can respect her and see her.
And we had an enjoyable time,
then it would be something different.
But, for me to just take a young girl
in a motel or something and I know
I'm more experienced than her.
She'd have to sit me
down, 21, 22 years old,
and let me know in her
words that she want this.
Because I think we go too far.
We don't respect the women.
Like I see some guys with some of the most
beautiful women in the world,
and they'll hit a drug or hit a crack pipe
or some crystal and say, okay,
get down there and suck it.
Or turn around and let me put it in.
And I ask them, I say do you
ever smell this woman hair?
Did you ever look in her eyes?
Do you feel the soft touch of her hand?
Even if you ain't in love with her,
you're just having some good sex.
Do you look at the smoothness
and the soft forms of her entire body?
Do you look in her eyes and appreciate,
and kneel down and say thank you Jesus
for this good time I'm 'bout to have
here with this beautiful angel?
This lovely lady.
But then we'll get a drug,
then we'll have more concern for the drug
and the alcohol than we
will the beautiful girl
that's sitting up there
butt-naked saying what about me?
We're buzzed and you started thinking
about that pipe or that
crystal or that alcohol
and I'm laying up here with all these
beautiful golden breasts,
all my parts is out
with this lovely brunette, with her head
in all the different
places that you like it.
And you're not even
paying attention to this?
And most men will make women feel like
it's a privilege to go to bed with them,
than for them to go to bed with.
Yeah that is true in some cases.
If she a slutty ass tramp
that don't nobody want.
But now you take a young lady like,
'cause some of y'all are like this,
these girls I just see on TV,
so I'm just using the famous stuff
because I don't know
where y'all at out there,
but there's a lot of y'all
out there just as beautiful.
You take a girl like Demi Moore.
Jennifer Lopez.
You think one of these
niggas can hit that?
Madonna, a young Madonna?
A young Janet Jackson?
You think they would be
caught with one of them?
And it wouldn't be about the money
with these type of ladies.
It would be about the honor
and respect you can give them.
'Cause these ladies have their own money.
And when they go out and get a boy,
it's just for a boy toy.
But they would like you
to appreciate and respect
what they're giving you and
what they're doing for you.
Because this type of girl you can't get.
But sometime, these type
of girls will run up
or wind up with the wrong person.
Crystal, crack, and these big dope dealers
will make you feel like, hey, you need me.
Because you're inferior to that drug.
And you don't.
If you look to your left,
and you look to your right,
he wanted to give you a lot of drugs
and have a little bit of money,
because it's just dope boy money.
And it's for cars, nice pretty cars.
But the guy on the right
wanted to give you millions,
and you could have had the
money to buy your own drug.
But you didn't take time
to look to the right,
because you was so buy paying
attention to your drug,
and you wanted to get high,
so you looked to the left.
And you missed all that on the right,
when you could have had the
money to buy your own drug,
the house, the car, and everything.
Because you were that beautiful.
But once you tried heroin, or
once you tried that crystal,
or that crack pipe, you started
getting low self-esteem.
And you didn't think you
were beautiful no more.
And you didn't think
you were worthy no more,
when you sling that long
brunette and that red hair.
Or that lovely brunette or
blonde, or even that auburn.
And that lovely black hair.
White girls with lovely long black hair,
with the pretty white
skin and them blue eyes.
Lovely women.
That beautiful black woman
from Asia and Africa.
Or that beautiful black woman
from America like Halle.
Berry.
Wouldn't you like to be in a
bed with something like that?
Instead of being down here with a tramp?
Those are the only ones
that can make these guys
feel like they need 'em.
And when I say tramp, that
don't mean you're ugly.
That means you're beautiful
on the other side,
but you's a tramp on the inside.
'Cause some of the most
prettiest ladies in the world,
I've seen 'em right here in Skid Row.
Are nothing but sluts and whores.
You think you're gonna go
home and take a shower,
and change your clothes and
just washes that all away.
And then you go out to
the club the next weekend
to have another dick in your mouth.
Or he'll go out and have another
piece of vagina in his mouth.
And y'all started cheating on each other.
Fucking over each other.
And there was no real love ever there.
Because remember, you wanted a man
that could give you good security.
Support you, you didn't
want nothing for love.
You wanted a girl that was gonna obey you.
And do everything you did, and stay home
and take care of your babies,
and look at the world on TV,
and never get to go to these places,
while you go to all these places.
You think she gonna sit at home
and read about Rome and
National Geographic?
Or just read about Paris
and look at it on TV
while you're there on your plane,
but don't want to take the wife and kids,
oh it'll be too busy,
'cause you got a lot of extra
baggage holding you down.
When you see that lovely female
looking at your big shoulders,
and you got all these babies
and this big fat woman with me.
Got married 20 years ago.
Or she looking, look at all
these young men looking at me,
I got these babies and this big fat slob
that sit up in front of the
TV and drink all the time.
That's what love is all about people.
All the things that we hate.
Not all the things that we love.
If love was like that,
then we'd all be happy.
We got our cars, we're happy.
Love is all about the
things that you hate.
You love him, so you're supposed to go
through that for him.
If life was gonna be
all smiles all the time,
everybody would love life.
But it's not.
Wake up and face reality.
That big, fat woman you
don't want to see no more?
That's who you chose to love 30 years ago.
Get used to it.
That's when love finally kicked in.
When you first marry each
other, it was just sex.
Good-looking, money, nice cars.
You grew up.
Now it's time to show the love part.
Love finally kick in.
I hate this bitch.
That's what you're supposed to feel
when you really love her.
'Cause once you feel
that, and stay with her,
and go through it, that's when she know,
that you truly love her.
Oh I hate this worthless
motherfucking drunk
that sit in front of the TV.
That's what you're
supposed to feel about him.
Once you see that and stay with him,
and still go through it, that
shows him that you love him.
He know that you're gonna
be there when you happy.
She know you gonna be
there when she happy.
The problem is will you be there
when she can't stand to look at your ass?
Will she be there when you
can't stand to look at her ass?
And better yet, will the kids be there
when they can't stand to see neither one
of you motherfuckers fighting no more?
So who will leave the home first?
And then who will break
up this family first?
Because the one that makes that decision,
like the movie Set It
Off, will set it off,
and make it easier for the rest
of the chains to break down.
'Cause once they see him
or her do it, the adults.
Well I don't give a fuck neither,
I don't care neither no more.
We can all just go our separate ways.
Okay, let's just do that.
Wow!
When's the last time you
talked to your brother?
I ain't talked to my
brother in 30 years, man.
30 years without calling.
When's the last time you
talked to your sister?
Oh, I ain't talked to that
bitch in 15 years, man.
That woman hates me.
When's the last time
you talked to your dad?
Oh my dad died, I never did get
to talk to him no more, man.
What about your mama?
She died.
Maybe my mom living
way out in Wyoming now,
and she done got old.
Where's your dad?
He moved back to Montana.
Started working on the farms again.
Where your sister?
Well she went to college
for a while in California.
Somebody gave her some
crystal then before I know it,
she got started on crystal,
and I ain't heard from her
in the last six years now.
What about you?
I had an embezzlement charge.
I was working for the FBI for a long time,
for the government.
I had a good office and Social Security,
but my wife divorced
me, took all the money,
now I got desperate and
started trying to cut corners,
and before I knew it the government
had charges for me for
embezzlement and all that.
I wind up going to federal
prison for about eight years,
and lost everything I had.
I got a little piece of job now, security.
I'm working at a library, but.
It never was the same.
What's wrong with you?
My house burnt down and I lost everything,
but you didn't lose your life.
And the government took everything,
but they didn't take your life.
And if you get that
down and that depressed,
that you feel life is over,
because certain events set
off certain other events
in your life, and you got so in the dump
and feel so sorry for yourself,
that you never did nothing
to try and replace it.
You just sat there sad like
a big 'ol sorry nothing.
And gave up.
Let me tell you this.
When I was 12 years old, my mother died.
My grandmother, she say.
If you feel a little bit of
water fall, it's tears of joy.
Not tears of sadness.
Because I'm proud the way
my people brought me out.
But my grandmother asked me when my mother
was on her deathbed, my mother
died before my grandmother,
and she followed not long after.
She said what is David gon' do?
She say I taught him
everything he need to know.
If he use it,
he'll be alright.
And I did come out all right.
Now I never went to school.
But I learned how to read very
well, anything on the planet.
And she gave me a good
understanding of life.
For the longest, I raised myself,
and I would walk,
and I would look at things,
and pay attention and
teach myself to learn.
And when I say I was an only child,
you have to remember what
comes with being an only child,
having no family, no wife, no children,
no brothers or sisters.
That means I never met her family.
She had a lot of sisters, brothers,
I never got the chance to meet them.
I think I've seen 'em once.
The only two people I got to meet
were my grandmother and my mother.
But now you have to remember
what comes with that.
When you think you've had a bad life,
you're looking at a man
that's never had a Christmas.
Never had a birthday.
Never had a Thanksgiving.
An Easter egg hunt.
A Halloween.
Never, ever having any celebration
for any holiday ever, that existed.
But that wasn't society's fault.
It wasn't anybody's fault.
That was just the way
life turned out for me.
And I had to accept that.
Just like you have to
accept a lot of things
that you don't want to.
And it's not personal.
It's only life.
And it will get easier to
deal with as you evolve,
as you give yourself a chance to learn,
and pay attention to
the things around you.
And remember these three songs.
Ain't got no kids no more,
husband done divorced you, done left you,
don't worry, be happy.
♪And every little thing,
gonna be all right. ♪
♪ Baby don't worry. ♪
And that Anita Baker song.
Ain't no need of worrying,
because it'll be all over in the morning.
And my point to society.
If you don't put so much into life
about what you don't have,
and appreciate the things that you do,
you won't stress out as hard.
And it won't mean as much to you
no matter what you get or
whatever you lose in life.
You always still got your life.
And I doubt I'll ever have
a Christmas or a birthday.
'Cause I'm 63 years old now.
But that doesn't bother me,
because I've had a lot of birthdays,
and a lot of Christmases, you know why?
'Cause it's not about the present,
or what somebody give you.
It's about being here.
63 years later.
Where all my friends got
shot down from gang banging
or killed for some reason.
Or the rest of them
went to prison for life.
I'm an old man, I have no
friends or homeboys left.
Because the ones I had are dead.
Or in prison for the rest of they life.
And they had birthdays, and
they got presents for Christmas.
But they're dead or
they're in prison for life.
I didn't get presents,
I didn't get birthdays.
But I'm alive and free.
So, no one will have it all.
No one will ever have it all.
And don't look at this water on my face
and think I'm sad, because I'm not.
The man that's doing this interview,
God brought him into my life.
And he's a good man.
And about two months ago I met this man.
Before I met him, I was
still appreciating life.
But it was just a little
bit harder before I met him.
And he made it just a
little easier for me.
And so no matter how many videos I do,
I'll do them all for him,
and I hope he do well with them.
And I hope these videos
will help a lot of people,
because that's what he's here for.
To help people.
And he's a good man.
And he keep bringing me back,
so he can get literature like this.
Not that he doesn't know it himself,
but he wanted to have somebody
who had been through it tell him.
And he didn't need my help, I needed his.
And I'm glad he did come into my life.
And I'm hoping that all young
people could use this video.
And see something here they can use.
And remember, it's about
living and enjoying life.
Not enjoying things, because
things will always come and go.
But your children and that
human flesh, that woman,
your brother, your sister, your mother.
You'll only have them for
a short period of time.
That means, one day,
some babies die at birth.
So that means you could
have your loved ones
for one day to 100 years.
But they'll only be here
for a short period of time.
And if you don't do the
right thing by them,
or by each other, while you here,
sometimes you will lose
that chance to do that.
And when you lose that chance to do that,
it will be something you will regret
the rest of your natural life.
In life and in death.
And you might not feel it now.
'Cause we never miss
the things we truly love
until it is gone and we
don't have it no more.
That's when we turn 'round and we miss it.
Like when we used to go to jail.
We would always get to jail
after the police catch us,
and say oh I coulda did
this I coulda did that.
But it's too late now, you in jail.
It's too late now that
person's dead and gone.
Or moved away.
'Cause in the end, no
matter what your belief is,
you gotta remember Cigarette
Man belief is being with God.
That's why I've never had
a tattoo or pierced ear,
a driver's license or a phone in my life.
I've never had any manmade appliances.
There's no tattoos, no pierced ears,
never had a driver's license, a phone.
None of that.
I'm a computer illiterate.
But I have met some good people
who have taught me just as much
as that computer has taught you.
So let's have a good day people.
Take care of your children,
love your loved ones.
This is me saying goodbye, Cigarette Man.
- [Mark] That's great.